[Music]
the next issue is the role of science
and scientists in public policy there is
a panel discussion moderated by Howard
Reese
Howard is the executive director of the
Union of Concerned Scientists and Howard
will introduce his past Thank You
Francis while everybody's sitting down
I've been answered I've been asked to
respond to two questions
one where is Tim Wirth's speech FedEx
arrived from his office this morning
unfortunately completely empty therefore
we'll make an effort to get it
transcribed and it will probably appear
at least on our website which is UCS USA
org sometime over the next several weeks
when we can make that happen
possibly also at MIT and elsewhere
secondly people have asked what is the
orange book outside that is actually a
sort of memoir that Henry Kendall had
been working on before he died it's a
collection of all of his articles
ranging from physics to his work in the
environment and national security and
some original sections that he wrote and
we worked with springer-verlag to get
published it just arrived from the
publisher this morning so there is a
flyer out there if you're interested you
can take one back with ordering
information we're gonna change tacks
here a little bit this afternoon we're
also going to give the audience a chance
to participate at the conclusion of our
panelists here you heard various talks
this morning about some of the more
serious critical issues facing our
future ranging from climate change to
nuclear weapons and biodiversity these
are all issues where it is absolutely
essential for policy makers policy
makers the media and the public to be
adequately informed about both causes
and solutions and where the scientific
community can play an important role
often there are controversies where the
data is insufficient or unclear
or where the scientific consensus has
not been adequately communicated or at
its worst deliberately clouded by those
who oppose action clarifying the
scientific consensus and mobilizing
scientists for thoughtful and effective
actions where goals that drove much of
Henry Kendall's work in the public arena
with the union of the Concerned
Scientists and other organizations
indeed today UCS has a large and
innovative project called the sound
science initiative designed primarily to
facilitate the participation of
scientists in public policy issues so we
thought it would be appropriate today to
spend some time examining the role of
scientists in the public policy process
from three different perspectives that
of a US Representative on Capitol Hill a
journalist with Newsweek magazine and a
senior official at the US Department of
Energy responsible for setting national
policy on some of the key issues we've
been hearing about today congressman
rush Holt is a Democrat from New Jersey
serving his first term in the US
Congress
I believe congressman Holt is one of
just two members of Congress with a PhD
in physics prior to his election in 1998
dr. Holt was assistant director of the
Princeton Plasma Physics Laboratory
Sharon Begley is a senior editor at
Newsweek magazine where she has worked
since 1977
MS Begley is well known for her ability
to translate complex scientific theories
or issues into compelling informative
and I'll underscore accurate prose she
covers a broad range of scientific
health and environmental issues as
exemplified by these three recent titles
the birth of the planets are we all a
little crazy and to walk on Mars dr.
Ernie Moniz is undersecretary at the US
Department of Energy where he is
responsible for R&D priorities on energy
environment national security and
fundamental science many of you here
will of course know him as Professor
Moniz from the Department of Physics at
MIT
I've asked each speaker to focus on some
broad questions about how scientific
input is assembled used not used or
abused in the media and the public
policy process and to comment on their
own personal experience as journalists
or scientists in decision-making roles
for example what's it like to be a
scientist on Capitol Hill
how did journalists sort out the facts
on complex controversial issues when you
have to meet a one o'clock deadline how
is national policy made when the science
is not yet clear or all the data isn't
in each speaker will have 15 to 20
minutes and then we'll have an
opportunity for them to react or ask
questions of each other and then we'll
open up the floor for questions from the
microphone after the discussion period I
want to show another short film and I
have to apologize I hadn't seen that
film we showed this morning and for a
while I thought it was 11 minutes it
turned out to be 21 minutes the film I
will show in a little while is only 59
seconds and I can guarantee you that it
is one of the last projects Henry was
working on at UCS so and I think it will
help tie some of the themes of the day
together so before we finish this panel
I will show you that so let us begin
with rush Holt
Thank You bud and thank you for inviting
me to be with you this afternoon
I don't venture as a freshman member of
Congress I don't venture very far from
central New Jersey often but for Henry
Kendall and for his memory I am pleased
to be here it's an honor I see a number
of friends many of whom I haven't seen
for years a few I've seen in recent days
dick Garwin in my office not long ago
but it is and I might add
dick embodies some of what I will be
talking about today which is effective
lobbying but Henry Henry Kendall was was
really a living testimony to how
scientists and politicians can work
together to further public welfare and
he testified numerous times of course
before Congress about issues of safety
and planetary survival but it's his
leadership of the UCS that particularly
impressed me it's deeply rooted in a
belief that with accurate information
public and policymakers ultimately will
make the right decision he had a rare
gift for taking a long view and
understanding how human activities and
natural systems are intricately
interconnected he encouraged all of us
to not shy away from from the big
problems facing the future of humanity
and the natural world and I think it's
fair to say that he used his scientific
abilities to identify those big problems
and to frame the questions
I have been a member of the UCS since I
think well certainly the early 70s I
believe since my first year in graduate
school and Henry Kendall was a role
model not not because I aspired or ever
expected to be a Nobel Prize winner in
my physics but because I was constantly
searching for ways to apply my science
for the public good and he offered a
model for doing that I'm often asked why
a physicist would leave a perfectly good
job helping to run a major research lab
to roll around in the muck of politics
I'd spent many years teaching at
Swarthmore College and elsewhere and
it's a long answer to long for this
discussion but there are several several
parts to it one is of course anyone who
knows my background knows that it's it
was in my blood I grew up surrounded by
politics
my father was a u.s. senator the
youngest person in fact ever elected to
that body and my mother was secretary of
state of West Virginia the only woman to
have held that position and although
most of through most of my career I was
working as a physicist in the laboratory
and the classroom I also was looking for
opportunities outside the classroom I
worked for the New York for a couple of
years for the New York City
Environmental Protection administration
I worked for the US State Department on
arms control and nuclear
non-proliferation for a couple of years
and I spent a year as an American
Physical Society congressional science
fellow
and that's when I really thought hard
about the interface between science and
politics science and Congress in
particular I certainly remember our
first week our orientation week as
congressional Fellows several dozen
mostly mid-career some young some older
scientists microbiologists chemists
physicists getting briefings from the
Congressional Research Service and the
Office of Science and Technology
Technology Policy and people from the
office of Technology Assessment rest its
soul and we were sitting there somewhat
nervous whether we had made the right
decision to leave the laboratory or the
classroom for a year to work on the hill
and one one speaker said now of course
you understand that here in Washington
facts are negotiable and we squirmed
nervously in our seats and the next day
as Speaker I think it was from the
Congressional Research Service who said
you must understand that here in
Washington we treat facts differently
and finally still a day later we were
beginning to understand what we had
gotten into when still another speaker
said of course in Washington perceptions
are facts
but we did learn a lot that year we
learned a lot about the role of science
in the Congress and what it does and
what science does and what it doesn't do
there we certainly learned this
important lesson that you've all heard
usually attributed to Tip O'Neill from
right down the street here that politics
all politics is local
and I think that even applies to global
warming global climate change and to
comprehensive test-ban treaty and any
number of other things the district I
represent in New Jersey the 12th
congressional district is a swath across
the central part of New Jersey from the
Delaware River to within four blocks of
the Jersey Shore it's a sprawling
suburban district and one of the best
educated in the country about two-thirds
of the people there have college
education nearly twice the national
average there's a heavy heavy
concentration of research and
development in the district and some
colleges and universities Panofsky knows
one of them of Princeton but also some
other fine less well-known colleges and
universities in the area in this
district there are some people who
appreciate the importance of research
and development in our economy to
maintain the kind of growth that we hope
we could maintain in order to deal with
almost anything else material that our
government deals with there are some
people who understand the nature and
role of science in society but really
not so many my district is not that
different from most district
around the country the scientists there
shy away from politics the politicians
they're shy away from science they often
seem to be in two separate worlds and
indeed it does seem that the perceptions
are factual I think I am in a privileged
position certainly in a privilege it is
a privilege to serve in the House of
Representatives to represent nearly
700,000 people to try to balance the
interests of 700,000 people something
that one former physicist who has worked
for many years on Capitol Hill talks
about as trying to feel the heft of the
different issues not to balance these
issues in any analytical way because to
do so would would overwhelm any bank of
parallel processors that you could come
up with but it is it is an honor and a
challenge to represent this to represent
this district the members that I serve
with in Congress are a remarkable set of
people most of them by and large very
very good at what they do
at balancing these interests it's
frustrating from the outside to watch it
and I must tell you from the inside it
is sometimes frustrating although having
worked on the hill as a congressional
fellow nearly two decades ago now and
having spent the intervening years
around Capitol Hill a great deal nothing
that happens there would surprise me it
is very effective at representing
society at large Congress and members of
Congress value science but they would be
hard
to tell you why they are the House of
Representatives is if nothing else
representative they represent the hopes
and the fears of the people of the
country and the misapprehensions of the
people at large the members of Congress
by and large are smarter than most but
not necessarily wiser than most
certainly none of us is wiser than the
collection of people whom we represent
and that's something Henry Kendall
understood and rekindle understood that
to influence public policy in other
words to lobby one use that used a
couple of approaches one appealed to the
wisdom of society at large and one
appealed Henry appealed to the wisdom of
individual members of Congress he
realized that it took a two prong
approach I feel that I have a
responsibility to try to help my
colleagues in Congress understand
science understand the terminology and
techniques and technicalities to the
extent that they are relevant to the
policy issues but also to understand the
role and goals of science
I was working under the tutelage I would
like to say of someone who who was
remarkably wise and who's lost we also
mourn this year and that's George Brown
congressman Broun from California
understood better than anyone in
Washington in the past 20 years if
you'll forgive me Ernie Moniz and others
he understood better than anyone in
Washington the role and nature of
science and was generally good at
communicating that but one person isn't
enough we need to work on communicating
that to the members of science I mean to
the members of Congress both directly
and indirectly through the input from
the citizens but ask me if I think the
views of scientists carry any special
weight on Capitol Hill and what factors
enhance or degrade the credibility of
scientists who want to participate well
there is significant credibility granted
to the independent and thorough approach
inherent in science and when scientists
are successful in articulating the
meaning of science and scientific
research in the ways that congressmen
general public can understand they're
then regarded as valued experts and
often asked for testimony and hearings
and consulted and legislative matters
they are seen as smart people but smart
people who might be able to argue
equally well on either side of the issue
you have your scientists and my
scientists it's apparent so in that
sense
scientists are sometimes in fact too
frequently seen only as another interest
group and this is accentuated when it is
apparent that so-called science is used
to develop predetermined results for
political needs as seems to be the case
in I would say the tobacco industry and
in other special interest groups as they
try to employ junk science to support
their position
so the sound science initiative that
Henry launched is is to be applauded a
misunderstanding of scientific method by
politicians can lead to problems like
the one that has developed regarding
public access to scientific data funded
under government grants a year ago at
this time of year as we approached an
appropriations trainwreck to use the
parlance of of Washington as we seem to
be approaching again this week and next
in an omnibus appropriations bill there
was hidden some language a Shelby
Senator Shelby insertion that requires
that all data obtained with federal
grants be available to requests under
the Freedom of Information Act
he was added without a hearing without
open discussion final regulations are
now in place and while the openness of
scientific exchange that exists in the
research community is vital to
maintaining scientific progress and
vibrancy this legislation instead of
creating more openness will I'm really
quite convinced create several problems
for the scientific community it will
subject researchers to harassment by
groups with ulterior motives the
universities will have to deal with the
costs and develop administrative ways of
responding to requests for information
as well as protecting their researchers
from those who wish to politicize
science the openness of scientific
exchange that exists in the research
community is vital for maintaining
scientific progress and this legislation
I think will make industries reluctant
to continue or enter into partnerships
with federally funded researchers once
data are commingled in a partnership it
may be difficult to distinguish data
produced with federal funds and those
produced with other funds the resulting
reluctance of industry to enter
partnerships will significantly hurt
fast-paced high-tech industries and is
another example tobacco
bunnies and organizations like the
National Rifle Association are already
using intimidation and freedom of
information threats to stop research
that shows that their products or
procedures are harmful this legislation
will open up researchers I believe to
further harassment I'm taking an active
role in combating this working to try to
repeal this provision here again the
late George Brown who had I think the
clearest grasp of the role in the
process of science recognized this
instantly he found this buried in the
Omnibus appropriations bill of last year
and immediately sought its repeal it's
going to take a while to build the
political support to get the repeal it
really depends on what effect these
regulations have on researchers but I
have now taken taken the principle
sponsorship of his of the George Brown
bill to repeal this I don't know what
the relationship was between Henry
Kendall and George Brown but I do know
that George Brown worked for at least
the last three decades on a number of
issues where he must have had close
association with Henry Kendall Viet
Nuclear Safety anti-satellite weapons
the banning of anti-satellite weapons
international science non-proliferation
to name a few and he like Henry was
fearless each of them put at risk their
principal work remember Henry got
involved in this he got involved in
politics he dirtied his hands before his
reputation as a scientist was as secure
as it eventually became
similarly George Brown would dirty his
politics with his fearless pursuit of
his vision where his clear thinking and
his scientific thinking led him
regardless of where the political chips
would fall long before he was safe and
in fact he was never safe politically
George Brown was at great risk every two
years as well a number of us are so it
is and that is why we honor Henry now
because he had this fearlessness he
recognized what was important and he
went after it damn the torpedoes but
also asked one way to improve the manner
in which scientific input would be
utilized in Congress well I can say that
simply one way to do it would be to
revive the office of Technology
Assessment I still shake my head in in
disbelief that Congress would abolish
the office of Technology Assessment you
know and say in effect don't tell us we
don't want to know but that's what
happened back in nineteen ninety five
and one hundred and fourth Congress and
the climate now will not allow its
rebirth I'm hopeful that in about a year
and a half the climate will be different
but we can talk about that
I won't sit down without mentioning
science education that's what it all
comes down to its dearest to my heart of
course in the ten years that I was at
the Princeton Plasma Physics Laboratory
certainly the I got the most
satisfaction from my work in science
education founding a program a series of
programs a number of programs in fact in
science education doing my best to
involve science scientists in the
schools it probably was the most
significant thing I did at the plasma
physics laboratory with all of the
important work that goes on there
promoting science education is a vital
step in in ensuring that the public has
an understanding of science not just an
appreciation of their fruits of science
but an understanding of the methods of
science to know how to evaluate sound
science from bogus science and it starts
in the earliest years I don't need to
tell you the importance of science
education for all students not just for
future scientists but for all citizens I
think it should take the form of every
science for every student in every year
so you don't have to wait till your
senior year to take physics or your
junior year to take chemistry it should
be integrated throughout but if you
think for just a moment what a
revolution that would be in your in the
training that you had to have more
integrated interdisciplinary science but
if you think about what a difference it
would make for an organization like UCS
if we did approach science that way
there was an article in The Washington
Post this week an excellent op-ed piece
by none other than Newt Gingrich arguing
why we must invest in research and
development
it was quite a good article Vern Ehlers
the other physicist in Congress who sits
on the other side of the aisle from me
copied the article and sent it out to
all colleagues previously I had talked
to my staff and I said should I stop
either sand send this out to all my
colleagues and I'm still kicking myself
that I didn't but he talked about the
not just the importance of the fruits
that come from a vigorous federally
funded research and development program
and what that meant for other research
and development programs privately
funded corporately funded and so forth
but he also talked about the lesson of
understanding he didn't put it in these
words but I would put it in these words
how to think that's the lesson that we
would learn from a science education
program that I envisioned for this
country a science education program that
teaches people why research is good not
just that it powers our economy that it
provides the new ideas that we need for
growth and productivity but a way of
thinking the challenges are previously
held beliefs we all as you know go
through life looking for evidence to
confirm what we think we already know I
envision a science education program
that leads students to use the methods
of science every day to challenge what
they think they already know Henry
Kendall did that on a societal scale and
that is why we celebrate him at his
memory today and I'm honored to be here
to join you in that celebration thank
you
thank you thank you rush it's very hard
to cut a speaker off when they keep
saying bud asked me to talk about this
so if you all do if you all do that
we're gonna be in trouble let me now
turn to the perspective of a journalist
Sharon Begley from Newsweek magazine
thank you when I saw the composition of
the panel that bud had put together for
this afternoon my first reaction was you
know let's just dispense with the
niceties and call us the forces of
darkness because you have on the one
hand Congress which served willfully
tries to torpedo environmental
legislation on issues that you all care
deeply about and the administration
which you know at least in the eyes of
some fails to show the courage and
leadership that many of us feel are
needed on environmental issues and then
of course the press which doesn't cover
the stories as well or as much as many
of you would like but there you have it
and it's nice of you to hold your that
said there is I think a lot of fairly
good environmental coverage in the press
but I'll focus on why there's not more
of it and why it's not better because
that's a lot more fun if you were my
reporters and I was the assignment
editor at a newspaper or a news
broadcast or a magazine here are some
stories that if you came and proposed
them to me I could almost certainly
guarantee you 50 column inches or two
minutes in primetime
DDT got a bum rap there was no reason to
ban it and doing so reflected junk
science and environmental hysteria TCE
has also been unfairly pilloried TCE is
best known as the organic solvent that
was present in the drinking water wells
in Woburn Massachusetts that's the town
where many of the children some of the
children died of leukemia it was a
subject of the book and then the movie
civil action third EPA's program to test
15,000 chemicals for and there
to current effects is also junk science
and a waste of taxpayer money and for
global warming and climate change will
be a boon to at least some regions of
the world
now these unfortunately are not
hypothetical examples because all these
are stories that ran and they did not
run and out-of-the-way outlets they ran
in in order the New York Times The New
Yorker the Atlantic and may occult the
Newsweek I won't read you from each of
them but I just took the DDT one I'll
read you a few of the excerpts many
scientists doubt the DDT is much more
hazardous than malathion this was
written when New York City was
apparently besieged by mosquitoes
carrying the West Nile virus and
undertook a program of aerial spraying
of malathion Rachel Carson had little
scientific expertise she mistakenly
claimed that DDT causes cancer which
wasn't proved then and still hasn't been
and then the obligatory quote from the
eminent scientist there's never been any
good evidence that DDT is harmful to
humans there's some evidence that it
hurts Birds but even that's iffy unquote
and finally DDT might have contributed
to the decline of populations of some
birds like eagles and falcons although
some scientists have long attributed the
declines to other factors so as
congressman Hulk was saying you have
your scientists and the other side has
theirs what I think these stories in
these stories selections illustrate is
that editors these days put a premium on
high drama on sensationalism and
especially on stories that appear to
contravene the conventional wisdom now
maybe it's to your credit that issues
like climate change and the pernicious
nosov environmental toxic is now
perceived as the conventional wisdom in
many spheres they are and therefore to
take a position questioning that is
deemed somehow good journalism or at
least worthy of some
sniff acun play because if nothing else
you get talked about and you get people
talking and I also don't know how we've
gotten to this point but to write a
story or to do a newscast that you know
really takes the position advanced by
the coal industry or the chemicals
industry is at least in many journalism
quarters perceived as somehow braver and
smarter than taking a line that would be
attributed to the environmental
community so that category of stories is
the first entry and what I would call
sir the taxonomy or the biodiversity of
stories that have elements of science
and public policy
the second category relates to quantity
rather than quality and it's one I call
the Franco syndrome those of you with
long memories will perhaps recall that
the Spanish dictator lingered on his
deathbed for weeks and weeks and weeks
and you know I suppose the wire services
did well they certainly could have moved
a story every day saying Franco was
still dying
Franco was still dying Franco was still
dying for many environmental stories we
have the problem of the world is still
warming species are still vanishing how
does it differ this week my editors
asked me from the conditions last week
or last month or last year there's a
reason these things are called
newspapers and news magazines and news
broadcasts for those of you who care
about these issues you have to make a
concerted effort to explain to people
like me what happened
what's different this week from last why
should I be doing it how can I convince
my editors that this deserves space more
than you know a movie review or an
earthquake or all of the other issues
that are competing for space and for air
time every day
the third category of story comes from
the multi handed reporter on the one
hand we have
on the other hand we have something else
on yet another hand we have something
else you see these kinds of stories
because reporters even those who cover
science as they're beat are not
scientists very few of them have science
training that's changing a little bit
but it will still for many years be the
case they therefore feel unqualified to
make judgments you can't get in trouble
if you simply repeat the arguments of
both sides this is a tried-and-true
technique it carries over from political
reporting from reporting on social
issues where if you are doing a story on
let's say school vouchers it's perfectly
legitimate to say this sighs that says
this will be the outcome of issuing
school vouchers so that parents can send
their kids to private schools with
taxpayer money the other says no this
will be the outcome for many issues like
that there simply is no defined answer
and by giving both sides you have you
have done your journalistic duty this
carries over into areas of science and
it is the job the responsibility perhaps
of those of you who care about these
issues to explain to people like me how
a question like climate change is not
like school vouchers there is a
consensus on climate change if you can
point out to me where to find it and
what it is and why that consensus exists
that will go a long way to disarming the
multi handed reporter now in all
fairness there's a lot of science that
is too new for there to be a consensus
one emerging issue is genetically
modified foods there was a paper just
over the summer in nature which looked
at fields that had been planted with
so-called bt cotton this is cotton that
is engineered to carry a gene so that
expresses the insecticide known as BT
turns out that in these fields plant
Bt cotton pink bollworms which are
leading cotton pests developed
resistance to bt it's very common this
has been the bane of the use of
insecticides since World War two
however the resistance was carried on a
recessive gene the scientists argued
that that was okay because given random
mating recessive genes generally are not
expressed they would not be expressed to
such an extent that the entire
population or a significant fraction of
the population of pink bollworms in any
field would be resistant to the
insecticide that you have engineered
your cotton to produce but other science
scientists came along and said but these
resistant insects develop more slowly
than the susceptible insects therefore
they would be out of phase for random
mating when the susceptible insects were
ready to mate they would mate with each
other but here you have these laggards
who tend who are developmentally slowed
but who carried the resistance gene
there's none of these guys to mate with
they mate with each other by simple
Mendelian inheritance a fair proportion
of them would therefore express the
resistance gene and you would have a
field of BT resistant pink bollworms
it's too early to know which of those
positions is right and all to be to do
justice to the story I don't think you
can do more than present both positions
as I said I think that's the exception
at least among the issues that we heard
described this morning where there is a
consensus opinion so I'd like to spend a
few minutes on how those of you who are
scientists and who care about these
issues can help us report them fairly
and accurately to repeat help us find
the consensus and understand it whether
it's the IPCC report whether it's a
National Academy of Sciences report
whether in a field very different from
those we're talking about today NIH
consensus conference these things exist
you can point us to them
second your I don't know if I should
call them opponents but those of those
scientists who say that DDT is not a
problem and was unfairly banned they're
very clever and you have to be equally
clever people who doubt the need for
regulation for environmental regulation
are often not very forthright about
what's known and what isn't it's
important for scientists to point out
that for someone to say there is no
basis for public policy generally for
tighter regulations on pesticides are on
co2 emissions that has a flipside there
may similarly be no basis for concluding
that current policy is justified that's
an important thing to remind reporters
of third too many reporters again
wearing the skeptics hat equate the
absence of evidence with evidence of
absence of harm generally again a lot of
us know that those two are not
equivalent scientists are often not
explicit about the distinction
especially scientists who oppose
regulation on the issues that we're
talking about again point that out to
people like me who call you forth
scientists especially on issues that are
highly polarized are more and more
labeling as false or wrong
interpretations of evidence that they
simply do not regard as valid I tore out
a commentary from Nature Biotechnology
on GM genetically modified foods and
eight times in the course of a one-page
article the scientists labeled as rumour
and innuendo allegations that there was
anything to worry about with genetically
modified crops here and I don't have to
remind this audience of this the more
accurate distinction is between facts
and hypotheses the debate over that is
one of the essences
when I call you about some issue it's
very helpful for you to explain to me
what are the facts what do we know based
on solid empirical evidence and what our
hypothesis hypotheses that deserve
further investigation fifth scientists
could be much more helpful and more
explicit about what is a value judgment
and what is a statement with again solid
empirical support at least some of the
people who downplay the risk of climate
change of loss of biodiversity of
environmental toxic s-- do so because
they see other issues as much more
important the lack of clean water to
much of the world's population tobacco
but they fail to say explicitly that
they are making a value judgment so when
someone says to me oh that's simply not
a major risk that's not an important
risk that's not a problem that we should
worry about I mean might see not seem
obvious that they're making a value
judgment but to a reporter listening to
a scientist often that comes across as
you know a scientific statement as
opposed to one that's laden with idiot
with ideology and politics again for
those of you who care about the issues
we heard about this morning it's helpful
for you to point that out I'll leave you
with one final hurdle or obstacle
scientists know that yesterday's heresy
can become today's orthodoxy
I'll reach way into the past so that I
don't trample on anyone's toes for an
example
continental drift in the early decades
of this century you would be laughed out
of the room if you said that the Earth's
plates were you know moving around like
the chocolate on a chocolate covered
cherry but today of course it's the
foundation of geophysics reporters see
some see it a little bit differently
reporters are convinced that today's
orthodoxy can turn out to be tomorrow's
and raise
or Polly water reporters are always on
the lookout for something which is today
accepted and conventional wisdom but
which might be overturned tomorrow
sometimes doing that takes precedence
over sorting out the facts
I actually actually don't think we need
Sharon's five or six step process we
just need to clone her a few thousand
times over let me now turn to Ernie
Moniz thanks bud
actually I think that's Brooke as as
Russia I'm sorry was was indicating I
think those of us as physicists in
Washington still are viewed with some
kind of suspicion and as a curiosity
certainly in my own role at do II just
two days ago I was giving a talk at a
meeting of the oh that better okay I was
just saying that certainly in in my role
perhaps as blood rush as a physicist in
my job still viewed as something of a
curiosity and many of the places the job
takes me two days ago I was giving a
talk to the western United States and
Canadian natural gas people guys drill
wells pipelines end-users and the the
introducer decided that it was
appropriate to tell a story that a
physicist he knew that I engaged
somewhat in in in in fishing in fly fly
fishing that a physicist was on the
stream before the season was opened the
warden came over and and asked him to
pull his fly out of the out of the water
preparing the course to to find him
physicists pulled out a magnet the
warden cited okay moved on the physicist
of course snickered he didn't know the
steel heads were running so
this is a not untypical reception of the
physicists in these in these jobs but
for the case I've certainly pleased to
have this chance to take part of the
symposium honoring Henry Kendall I've
certainly personally had the opportunity
to admire Henry for essentially my
entire physics career indeed in my first
year of graduate school at Stanford I
worked in the dictator's group in the
Friedman Kendall Taylor collaboration
that proved to be so productive in my in
my absence of course since I then moved
on to a different group here at MIT also
particularly in my years as department
head in physics Henry was always very
supportive and I just wanted to stress
he was always there also for discussions
and action in terms of undergraduate
education particularly laboratory
experiences I was one of the areas that
he he focused on and in my more recent
public service career Henry of course
stands out as I think as one of the
truly great physicist contributors to
shaping important public policy debates
by the way in the program it says I will
give a perspective from the White House
but actually I will do do eat which is
sort of half way between Capitol Hill
and the and the White House let me know
some of the ways in which Henry
contributed to the diverse portfolio of
Department of Energy activities indeed
in some ways the diverse do eportfolio
almost seems to be put together as a way
to engage to engage Henry science energy
environment and nuclear national
security issues all of which he was
engaged in in science of core do we is
the largest supporter of basic and
Applied Research in the physical
sciences and of course Henry's role in
the work recognized by the Nobel Prize
speaks for itself in his contribution to
to particle physics a field that for
which do e is the is the principal
steward but but beyond that a major
study done about four years ago the so
called Galvan study was one that has
helped reshape our approach to at least
trying to get a more of a corporate
engagement of our laboratories with with
the
with the Department and Henry was a was
a very important member of that of that
commission in energy and environment the
department's responsibilities range from
environmental remediation of the Cold
War
legacy mess to addressing sustainable
development through new energy
technologies and energy policies Henry
again contributed contributed in a major
way in both areas perhaps less well
known that the latter is in the former
that is the issue of environmental
remediation again on the Galvin
Commission Henry was the principal
driver and principal author for a
chapter that emphasized the need for the
department to engage its laboratories in
technology development to help
environmental remediation to do it
faster perhaps to do it cheaper and more
and perhaps even more important to drive
towards better end States as we try to
clean up this this mess that agenda that
Henry set out and really was the
principal driver for is not an easy one
to implement but I think we are making
progress and indeed the last two days
I've been in in Idaho precisely to
advance that agenda that Henry Henry set
out in terms of bringing science and
technology to bear on this important
environmental challenge of course you've
already heard this morning about Henry's
extensive work on the stainable world
one that can help improve the lives of
enormous number of the world citizens
while preserving our environmental
values again I would just say that do
E's principal role here is in addressing
new energy technologies that in fact
address environmental challenges and all
geographical scales from local in an
urban environment to the global issues
that Bob Watson certainly discussed this
morning finally in national security and
again dick Darwin covered many of the
issues the department's principal role
is as steward of the nuclear weapon
stockpile and as a lead agency for
nuclear non-proliferation particularly
through our work in Russia to prevent
the spread of nuclear weapon
nuclear materials and nuclear weapons
know-how Henry's last service to the
government I believe the program notes
this came when he signed out in February
of this year the child's Commission
report this was a report which has
served is serving the Department of
Energy very well it's a report that
focuses on the human resource needs to
maintain the nuclear weapons stockpile a
declining stockpile in the absence of
nuclear testing and in fact that
challenge the the human challenge in
that program is an important one and our
ability to manage that challenge and to
convince Congress that we have managed
that challenge will be very important in
the remaining discussions in the next
year's on the CTBT so as you can see
from this sort of discussion of what the
Department of Energy is about and areas
in which I'm certainly engaged my
personal answer to the charge of his
panel the role of scientists in in
public policy is basically working out
Henry Kendall's agenda he really did
advance advances in all of these and all
of these ways he was one of I think a
number of faculty here at MIT elsewhere
as well but I will focus on my home base
at MIT who I think by valuing public
service and demonstrating it really
helped a number of us certainly in my
generation to accept the challenges as
they as they came forward the the role
of the role of scientists and public
policy is of course built in the role of
science in public policy and as I just
reviewed for the do-e science of
technology underpins everything we do
and yet there are very few scientists in
senior roles where decisions are taken
in in the administration and including
in the Department of Energy which again
is basically a science and science
agency thus the the major role for most
scientists for most
whether inside or outside the government
tends to be in conveying scientific
information and judgment to the non
scientists lawyers etc who in fact are
those in most positions making decisions
that dialogue I think needs to be based
on some very simple principles the
information and judgments need to be
truthful yet streamlined and without the
endless hierarchy of qualifications that
sometimes characterizes scientist
communications it needs to be without
arrogance particularly without disdain
for politics because that is the
business of reaching decisions and it
needs to be regular and not just offered
in response to a funding shortly or a
shortfall I think that guidance typifies
scientific advice that tends to be
effective let me just mention a few
examples of the types of scientific
interaction that I think we need we need
to be able to reach good good choices
good policy good programs one roll one
up one obviously important role it's
very important for 4d Yui certainly one
very important role is to the scientific
community to help shape science support
there's no need to go going in here into
the to the role of science in our in our
society in our economy etc Rush touched
on that I just want to emphasize because
even though it's obvious I think it
happens not frequently enough emphasized
the importance of community processes in
coming forward to Washington I think
when when a community is coming in and
speaking together having gone through
its internal discussions sometimes
bloody to reach a space set of
priorities and sticks to it it's a very
very effective way of moving the whole
political system let me give you one
example in fact I'll draw upon Russia's
own
on the professional field before
politics that is in infusion Fusion is a
case where the fusion plasma science
area is a case where the program was
going along frankly I think having some
problems within the community in terms
of its directions Congress in the end
decided that it was time for that field
to reevaluate its its future the message
was pretty clear it was a 30% cut in
funding in one year to the next
this was very difficult as Rush knows
some staff in the Congress etcetera
reviewing that as simply the first step
towards continued major declines in that
field I think that community deserves a
lot of credit what they've done is in a
dialogue involving OSTP do-e OMB
the Congress and the community they have
in what's difficult process pull
themselves together done a joint road
map provided a common vision as to where
they're going and in fact this year the
budget is now starting to turn up and I
believe the field is on a much stronger
scientific foundation and one that
promises very important science results
and perhaps even in a long-term and
energy future so again but the message
here is I think there's an example of
the community getting together really
having frank discussions about their
about their field where it was going
coming working with the government in
shaping their vision and in fact I think
being on a on a very very sound
foundation to go forward let me turn to
a second area relevant at D OE where I
think scientists again working together
government scientists those from the
from universities in this case industry
as well coming together in mapping out
an applied research future namely that
involving energy to energy
technologies frankly in the book this is
actually again a legacy in a certain
sense of the Galvan report that Henry
Henry worked on that report emphasized
the importance of having do ii sort of
reorganize its portfolio and engage in a
road mapping process going forward to
identify the important areas of applied
research that best aligned with our
policy goals our environmental policy
goals for example policy goals involving
private sector developments such as
restructuring etc that lesson was taken
to heart I think it's an example where
it shows I think the importance of our
trying to get more scientists into
senior positions because what happens is
in this case and I think it's a good see
it's a good good example I think by
having senior decision-making scientific
leadership one is able then to energize
the senior career technical people to
work with the community and have an
effective process that process this year
has gone forward and without going into
details it is put new energy into the
program and that was not a pun put new
energy in the program and in fact
identified three or four major gaps in
the portfolio major opportunities going
forward that will serve our energy goals
and serve our environmental goals so I
think again having emphasizing the need
for us to get I think more scientists in
these kinds of positions I think will
help get more of these kinds of what I
view as very positive results and
finally let me turn to the issue of
science is the science role in framing
shall we say major policy decisions
fundamental decisions involving the
economy or the environment or national
security what I want to do is just just
emphasize one one one one point
which can sometimes be frustrating to
scientists but I think in no way
minimizes the importance of their
interaction there are of course a number
of areas and I I can mention regional
effects of global warming I can mention
our our attempts at resolving long-term
geological isolation of nuclear waste I
can mention the recent discussions in
terms of stockpile stewardship and the
CTBT debate brief debate as areas that I
would say have a sort of a common one
common element they are areas in which
clearly scientific technical input is
absolutely critical to reaching
decisions but in some sense isn't enough
data are incomplete
yes but one can argue that even with
complete data that remains the need for
a political decision because at some
level there is a a balancing of risk
long timescales in what is not a purely
scientific judgment if I just take the
the issue of Yucca Mountain and nuclear
waste one can imagine in that case that
one has done all of the experiments one
wishes in terms of measuring water
percolation and measuring ion exchange
coefficients of radionuclides and you
know and doing engineered barriers etc
one still faces the issue of a decision
that's being taken roughly speaking on a
ten thousand year time scale stockpile
stewardship it's not a ten thousand year
time scale but it's a thirty year time
scale let's say in terms of providing
assurance in terms of safety and
reliability of weapons without integral
testing I mean dick borne and it went
into some of the reasons why we think
that that is in fact
a very very sound program and one that
doesn't merit are committing to the CTBT
but the fact is there are issues that go
into a political sphere and scientists I
think cannot get discouraged from from
continuing to continuing to engage in in
these in these discussions sometimes it
is frustrating I'll just mention that in
the CTBT discussion a discussion
I had two weeks ago with an unnamed
senator involved his saying that in the
end he had no real substantive objection
to the CTBT but that it just seemed too
much like gun control and he he did not
vote for the for the CTBT but I think
what I wanted to I'll just end up by
saying that I think there is this this
issue of a number of very important
scientifically based decisions that have
to be made ultimately political
decisions have been made where this
issue of how one evaluates risk in the
context of very very long timescales is
a difficult issue particularly in the
face of rather extensive scientific
illiteracy and so I think there are two
pathways there which we need to work on
actually rush already addressed the
issue of improving scientific literacy
in the long term as a very important one
but the issue also as to how the science
community can find the right way to
discuss these kinds of questions where
you need lots of scientific information
but you also have to supplement that
with a discussion of risk in the context
of long timescales it's difficult one
and but a task worthy I think of those
who wish to carry on Henry's and his
work thank you
thank you all for those very insightful
talks let me first ask the panelists
whether they have questions for each
other or responses to the comments made
by each other and then we'll turn it
over to the audience
I mentioned that there's a question for
rush I mentioned that reporters at least
tried to find you know the consensus
document or the consensus point of view
friends who work at the Academy talk
about how their reports even when
requested directly by Congress just fall
into a black hole on the hill I'm
wondering how much weight again and
National Academy of Sciences report
carries relative to other considerations
well I can't speak from long experience
on the hill but I can speak from fairly
long experience around the hill and
short experience as a member I would say
that at a of the National Academy of
Science and say along the lines of this
prevalent view of science as another
interest group a report from the
National Academy of Sciences has
slightly more slightly more effect than
a study from any other think-tank
scientists are generally regarded as
smart people so it's smart people that
worked on it but there is I think not
much appreciation of the of the system
and the controls that go into a report
from the from the National Academy in
other words it is not much of an
appreciation there is not a great
appreciation of the scientific approach
and contribution to to a study other
questions or comments
I have a question for Sharon although
it's probably more just an expression of
frustration but any advice you can give
would be would be welcome represent last
week I was quoted in in a one of the
newspapers you mentioned in your in your
in your stories the first one in fact
and it was frustrating was this was a
case where the reporter who in my view
is generally a very good reporter called
close to the deadline asked for a
clarification master a certain issue it
was totally wrong I said it was wrong
and so the result was the article was
printed as it was except with him I
quote at the end which made absolutely
no sense in the context of this article
and I guess the it's a question
observation question advice that can be
the most frustrating thing but I think
you described the relevant parameters
the guy was probably an hour so from
deadline he had written the top twenty
six inches of his story and he left the
bottom inch for you and this is you know
another example of the multi handed
reporter even if you had conveyed this
this criticism to him directly again not
knowing who it was but I think the
reaction would be ok but I gave you if
not equal space at least some space but
you know and reporters are all too human
but because we are we are also very
amenable to being corrected nicely so if
you were to call this person you know
once a couple of days had gone by and
point out your unhappiness with this not
just personally but because it conveyed
you know it left a misleading impression
you know at least next time at least the
exact same mistake would not happen
again which is not to say new mistake
wouldn't happen but it's worth just
picking up the phone I'm surprised that
not more people call me to tell you the
truth I get calls from PR people all the
time but when something is in the news
and you as
you know a respectable scientist has
something to say you know all of us pick
up our phones we don't even have
secretaries I would just urge more of
you who care about these issues to be I
hate this word but proactive if Sharon
you wanna give out your phone number
[Laughter]
well well
Ernie was asking that and Sharon was
answering I thought of of an
illustration of the point I wanted to
make about National Academy studies
there was as you may know a National
Academy study some time in the last year
I suppose it was dealing it was sort of
a wrap up of the biological effects of
electromagnetic radiation as I recall
non ionizing radiation there also was
this week a segment that I didn't see I
gather it was a few minutes long on the
television program 20/20 dealing
reviving the issue of whether cellphones
produce brain tumors that segment has
caused as much of a buzz on Capitol Hill
the 20/20 segment as this lengthy
thoughtful report from the National
Academy dealing with electromagnetic
radiation it's you know it used to be
said you don't you don't mess around
with those who buy ink by the barrel in
politics but but of course now they that
was that was was a Jim Farley who said
that I can't remember but it was that
was about 70 years ago but now of course
it would mean those who own the airwaves
and a segment on 20/20 by those
reporters those well I hesitate to use
the word journalists because I think
journey I I used the word journalist in
a in a positive sense and I it seems to
me this was from the little bit I know
about it
irresponsible science and so you don't
argue with people who own the airwaves
last word from the panel now I'm not
quite sure how we take questions we may
have a roving mic or it's a fixed mic
but this gentleman has taken the lead so
it is a fixed mic why don't we do this
and one other legacy that Henry Kendall
left us that you may not be aware of
that he brought a 10-pound gavel to our
board meetings and I know how to use it
very effectively so we'd like please to
make your comments or primarily
questions very brief and we'll try to
accommodate as many people as we can and
state your name please
Thanks well I guess you're well the
gavel is coming and what kind of late I
guess I just I rushed up here out of
impatience I'm sorry to say my name is
James Williamson and I'm glad to be here
for this panel because I'm a candidate
for City Council here in Cambridge and I
heard mention of all tip O'Neill's great
saying all politics is local which gives
me the opportunity to come up with a
couple of questions which I think will
be interested it'll be interesting to
hear your response to the first is that
there is one question on the ballot for
voters in Cambridge this coming election
day and it has to do with nuclear
weapons and it asks the citizens of
Cambridge to approve a message calling
upon the President and government of the
United States to engage other nuclear
nations in negotiations for a nuclear
weapons convention an international
treaty requiring a specific timetable
for phased elimination of nuclear
weapons including effective verification
and enforcement measures so my first
question would be if any of the
panelists or anybody else might have a
comment on this especially in the light
of what I unfortunately had to miss but
was a as I understand it an interesting
discussion about related issues by mr.
Garland
the second thing is in terms of the
environmental issues that Henry Kendall
focused on I think we have some
environmental issues here in Cambridge
and I wonder if any of the panelists or
perhaps anybody else might have
something they might wish to say about
that all all politics is local all
science and public policy is local and
in Cambridge just as one example that
relates to climate change in Cambridge
there's an enormous boom of commercial
real estate so-called development in the
city involving paving over much of the
city reducing green space reducing open
space creating huge parking lots that
have in entail traffic generation
so my question is is this responsible
policy in the light of what we
understand about the implications for
climate change and the environment what
if you'd like to respond this is rush
hold wearing my political hat I would
say in my experience local statements of
that sort on international strategic
matters are not particularly persuasive
to to those negotiating or making making
the decisions and you know it's not that
it's certainly within more than within
the rights and maybe within the
interests of the local political
organizations to to advance them but I
don't think that it that they're
particularly effective with with regard
I mean I think what UCS has done along
those lines you know when it comes when
it came to anti-satellite weapons and
that sort I think has been much more
effective with regard to loss of open
space just a brief comment we've had
serious flooding in in New Jersey
following the hurricane this this past
month and I wanted to write an op-ed
piece about what we learned from those
floods and from recent data of
streamflow the rise rise time of streams
during flooding what we learned about
the you know if there was any
correlation with the loss of permeable
ground in New Jersey
and my staff trained mostly in politics
and not in science we're I I'm telling a
little story on them I suppose but they
were mystified that I would ask for this
that
that we might do a little experiment
here looking at the data and and write
up an op-ed piece on it that did not
draw from anything that had come from
the White House or or the or the caucus
of our party that there were some
lessons to learn in a simple scientific
way it is hard in in this society to get
two people to look at simple questions
of that sort
as scientists Ernie let me just add a
few comments first on the nuclear
weapons issue you raised as a member of
the NPT of course we are committed to
ultimate movement towards elimination of
nuclear weapons but that is of course
discussed in a very broad context of
overall military posture etc and as Rush
said a specific date at this stage I
mean it might be a good political
expression I don't think it will move
things quite as much today as trying to
maintain the progress that the NPT
commits us to in things like the CTBT
things like moving to start 3d Garland I
guess it's not here right now but he he
discussed it earlier we are trying to
move towards in fact one of the things
dick mentioned I should say he talked
about moving beyond launchers to weapons
and in the star 3 process we would be
able to start going in that direction
including verification transparency if
you like in warhead dismantlement so I
think there are very specific agenda
items out there that would make a big
difference
over the next over the next decade and
certainly I think that that's that's
where our focus remains with regard to
the issue you raised in terms of
environmental issues and in Cambridge
although I will say it's obviously for
other cities and towns as well
let me just make one point I mean
there's the obvious issue as you talked
about open spaces etc very important but
there are other issues going on all the
time that are also very important and
sometimes don't get the the attention
they tend to be more technical and I
think our our areas where again
scientists and engineers can make useful
inputs let me just get tell it in the
story of a story of MIT I think Francis
may have been Provost when Bill Dixon
started them the the movement towards
the combined heat and power plant the
the gas turbine this is an example where
MIT wanted to build its own I forget how
many 20 megawatts or something gas
turbine to provide heating cooling
chilled water for the campus
environmentally one one one phrasing of
its environmental benefits was that it
was equivalent to saving 10,000 commutes
to Cambridge per day it was bill must
have started this in 1984 or something
nominally being allowed by changes in
the regular regulatory structure but in
fact Francis you must know it I think it
took 12 years to to accomplish because
of issues of how technical regulatory
issues were being handled these are the
the monopoly utilities etc these are
technical issues very important as we as
we move forward in evolving the energy
system in ways that will ultimately have
major environmental impacts ok the next
question please and my name is Henry
Myers I'm asking this question to
congressman halt and the context of the
CTB having been an issue when more or
less in his present form for more than
40 years yes I know there's how do you
explain the congressional majority
having a view of the CTB that differs so
much from
those expressed today budget Garwin I
don't have a good explanation
I really don't I their there's after
yeah after all these years I don't have
a good explanation why why they have
turned wise opponents of that have
turned a blind eye to the very cogent
arguments and persuasive arguments of
the arms control community let me for
shorthand call it that over the years
I'm sorry I wish I did but obviously the
proponents of the ratification didn't
have the answer to this either anybody
else want to take a stab at that one I
will and I'll give you three or four
answers one I think the timing was very
unfortunate this was clearly an effort
that needed a longer timeframe for the
proponents to prevent a prepare for and
to make their case and because the vote
would the debate was limited to twelve
days it was a massive task on our end to
try to to have make the arguments that I
think would have been important I think
was obviously a very political and very
polarized debate that had as much to do
with getting Bill Clinton as it did
stopping the treaty and I think
unfortunately that polarization created
a climate in which the few people who
really for their own reasons wanted to
oppose this treaty I think for wrong
reasons could dominate and a lot of it I
think is just timing that it was very
unfortunate except to argue the
arguments aren't new the arguments have
been around in their present form for a
very long time that's right that's right
but I would agree with your observations
there's no question this was a staged
defeat yes it was staged out of a hatred
for the president there is you know
hatred is a destructive sentiment and
there are some on Capitol Hill who just
can't stand the president
and and it clouds their judgment in some
cases and they and it was part of what
was going on here but it doesn't answer
I don't think it answers the the
question of why after all these Trent
Lott was able to recognize that there
was not sufficient support and so if he
he could stage a defeat of it this way
by bringing it up quickly but it does
not accept and he recognized this lack
of support support but the question
remains why was why is there out in
society this lack of support and and
among societies representatives this
lack of support after all these years of
cogent arguments I'll just add one one
last word first of all I agree with more
or less the political observations which
have been made although I do point out
of course that certainly polls indicate
that roughly 80% of the public in a
nonpartisan way support the
comprehensive test-ban let me just add
we'll get there
we're gonna get there it's going to take
another couple of years probably the
other thing I would just mention and
this does go back to the scientific
discussion and bud says that was not
perhaps the time to do this but we do
have to make a better articulation of
the science-based docpath stewardship
program and we need to articulate better
what the verification issues are I think
dick dick Garwin said it correctly no
one's going to argue that one has
verification down down to zero that
isn't the point in going to zero yield
however we feel very confident that
militarily or strategically interesting
testing programs would be detected and
so ultimately the question that never
got asked is no matter what how you
assign risk to some of these issues and
there will be a difference of opinion as
to how you assign risk and detail
no one ever finally came around to
asking the question really are you
better off with the treaty or without it
and I don't think any reasonable
assumption of risk could possibly lead
to the to the to the conclusion that you
were better off without it
next question please
Judy Gilmore from Rhode Island I am
concerned I went I was hoping that those
scientists of you who are working in
Washington would be able to help us
focus on how scientists can be effective
create an effective interface with
decision makers who innately either
field that decisions are always
negotiable or or that they can be bought
when we're used to dealing with more
finite entities as you are looking at
well what made us have a flood this time
and what can we measure so we're used to
looking at measurable right things that
you can ultimately hopefully prove right
or wrong and you're all the decisions
are being made by people who ultimately
don't accept anything as finite and who
feel they can negotiate their way out of
any box thank you well of course it's
interesting you know scientists are much
more comfortable with uncertainty than
politicians are believe it or not and
you know even though scientists have
this reputation obviously for being
dealing only with cut-and-dried facts in
the op-ed piece that I referred to that
was written by Newt Gingrich this past
week talking about research and
development he asked the rhetorical
question well why is it that this that
scientific research has not gotten the
support it should and he said in his
experience and I would confirm this I
would concur with this anyway that
scientists are among the worst
lobbyists that he has ever seen and I
think we really have to we have to work
on that there are some a few in this
room Henry Kendall and others who have
over the years been effective lobbyists
up to a point but by and large
scientists are not good if you're
looking for specific techniques there is
a nice handbook on some of the kind of
specifics of dealing with members of
Congress written by Bill Wells William B
Wells published maybe 10 years ago or
less published by the American
Association for the Advancement of
science I think there was a joint
publishing effort and I do and it was
something like communicating with
Congress a guide for scientists and
engineers maybe a hundred or 150 pages
long a nice book I recommend it to you
I'm not sure whether it's still in print
but it's it's on the Internet William B
Wells so I recommend that to you for
techniques good tip thank you we'll take
three more questions and that will be it
because you guys have done a good job in
keeping it short so go ahead I'm Burton
Richter and a physicist and this is
addressed to rush Holder and Sharon
Begley most scientists think that there
is a way to arrive some sort of
consensus on scientific issues whether
they be the science behind the test-ban
or the science behind global warming yet
Congress does not seem to want to set up
such a mechanism you rush said that not
only did they abolish OTA but there was
no way to set it up again for at least a
year and a half and Sharon Begley if I
can paraphrase her characterize science
reporting generally as short sensational
and shallow now
is there what is your perspective from
both the media and from Washington and
how one can set up some sort of system
that our government and the press can
draw on to get the best consensus on
complicated issues science doesn't give
you all the answers as politics or
judgments and all the rest of it but
there certainly is scientific fact and
scientific uncertainty but Congress and
the press don't seem to want to find it
or make use of it comments please as I
said at the beginning of my remarks I
was focusing on the the stories that
fall short of the ideal I think in all
honesty we have to say that coverage of
let's say the climate change issue does
reflect the consensus expressed in the
IPCC reports more than it does what
comes out of the University of Alabama
for instance and the greening Earth
Society which sends me something every
week letting us know that it exists is
crucial I cover science and
environmental policy and my counterparts
at Time In The New York Times and The
Washington Post do but in the huge
majority of the papers in this country
the person who gets handed the you know
the greenhouse story for that week is
very likely you know going to cover the
the sewer bond issue next week they are
not specialists they mate let alone
whether they can evaluate the
information they often simply do not
know that the information is out there
to be evaluated and it's a horrible
thing to say the level of ignorance out
there on the part of people who are
being paid to cover this beat but it is
there and it's a fact of life which
scientists who are interested in these
issues have to find a way to work around
which I keep coming back to pick up the
phone send people a piece of mail your
voice will have a greater weight or
volume if it comes from triple-a s or
ApS when a group of scientists get
together either VA professional Society
or some other
some other organizing principle and
comes out with a pronouncement on an
issue that does carry weight and it is
covered yes there may be the almost
obligatory inclusion of a quote by
someone by a scientist who disagrees
with that conclusion but I think by and
large the consensus opinion will be
conveyed in the stories yes sir
well Bert let me just say I mean keep at
it well the the OTA was disbanded for I
think much the same reason that the
what's now called OSTP was disbanded
under Nixon it was delivering you know
information that wasn't seen as
dispassionate it was delivering I guess
what some saw as judgments that they
didn't want to hear and you know
scientists of course should not expect
don't have the last word on balancing
the interests but science certainly can
provide constraints on what is possible
and we have still a lot of public
education to do to help policymakers
understand that and so you know please
keep at it
I mean I'm keeping at it trying to
revive such things as the OTA in the
meantime make sure that every think-tank
that you know of consult scientists in
in some of their in some of their
studies I just like to add one thing
although it's less now than it was ten
years ago
there still seems to be an attitude on
the part of at least some in the
scientific community that to enter
politics not in an elected capacity as
Russia's but just simply to weigh in on
an issue or god forbid to call a
journalist is sullying yourself somehow
and as a result some of the smartest
people just will not get involved in a
way that could be beneficial to the
issues we're talking about here there's
still a perception that the public
scientist is not a true scientist
anymore that he or she has sold out has
gone you know has gone popular and
therefore will lose the the esteem of
his or her colleagues I'm gonna
reiterate that suggestion one more time
don't just call your congressperson call
your friendly reporter yes sir
my name is sastra majora but I'm
international known as say no the best
thing is to make a demonstration
question and demonstration the same time
I dress it to the lady in the middle if
you stack up three fingers of your left
hand and please say of your right hand
and I ask you three and see how much is
that what will you answer six six fine
if I ask you do you like your mother but
what do you answer yes I say yeah even
if she is horrible to you or something
but it is my mother I like her no that
is the thing is fundamental education we
call three plus three in Indonesia we
call a rational thinking and yes I like
my model no matter what we call that the
feeling of feeling emotion but that is
never never never a forgiving in
Indonesia and I don't know in the rest
of the world in grade school three great
school great school up to you're a
minister doctor that is they forgive it
in school but I have always given this
the basic basic thing in my student and
I gave already lectures in 1941 when
there was not even a republic I'm I'm
here from from MIT I've finished here
and then it was cold here that is when I
came back here after 40 years and June
the reunion could I actually finish up
quickly please thank you thank you sir
do you still have that thing I want to
buy it it's not there anymore yes thank
you very much last question please well
I have a question for Ernie Moniz I'm
dick Garwin and this guy's I worked on
an Arab energy research advisory board
panel in 1989 or 1990 looking at cold
fusion and this year the Department of
Energy I noticed has a nuclear energy
research initiative that I supported in
the abstract but one of the ten I think
awardees is George Miley at the
University of Illinois who has a big
grant to look at cold fusion and eating
up radioactive materials in that process
and I was just wondering how the
Department of Energy what decision
procedure it uses in this case thanks
dick the the Neary program that you so
wisely supported is it's let me say a
couple of words it's a it's a new
program this year small program 19
million dollars which is looking at
reviving research in some sense in terms
of longer term views of nuclear fuels to
clear field cycles proliferation
resistant fuel cycles etc the program is
it's a peer-reviewed program competitive
peer-reviewed program I would say the
program is learning how to do peer
review it is it is it has not been the
custom in that program to do that I
think by and large the process worked
extremely well there was one award
tentative award that raised some issues
it has gone back for a second round of
peer review which is completed but I
would not discuss it here you know there
is an old tradition that if something
falls in disrepute you change the name
and I gather there's a resurgence now of
chemically-induced
fusion well thank you very much I
promised that I would show this short
film
I took we took a risk this morning and
putting together this program in
starting with science and religion which
is like oil and water I'm now going to
spend a couple of minutes on science and
Hollywood which is an equally unlikely
mix but this was a fascination of Henry
Kendall he would often call me each week
and say gee that entertainment industry
has an awful lot of power and ability to
reach people isn't there some way we
could harness some of that he made some
forays out to Hollywood most of the time
unsuccessful but finally they bit and a
group of people came to us about six
months ago and said they would like to
make a public service announcement on
climate change they needed help with
keeping the facts straight and with the
Union of Concerned Scientists like
help and my first reaction and Henri's
was well it'll be a PSA you'll come on
at 4 o'clock in the morning we're not
gonna reach very many people and they
said no you know when you go to the
movies and you sit there and you see
previews of upcoming shows that's the
spot we want to give you and we're going
to give it to you in 8,000 movie
theaters across the countries for two
months so we proceeded and what you will
see in a few moments has not yet been
seen east of California it has started
appearing in movie theaters in
California it will move east over the
next several months in many ways it is a
tribute to Henry because he started it
but equally important I think it's
apropos to this panel we heard a lot
about how to better articulate and make
our case both the policy makers the
media and the public Bob Watson went
through maybe 65 or 70 overheads this
morning I think if you picked out a few
themes in there one of them or two of
them were climate change is likely to
screw up the hydrologic cycle it's
likely to make some places wetter in
some places drier we tried to take that
and distill it with friends in Hollywood
down to 60 seconds and this is the
result and then after this film I'll
turn the podium back over to Francis
Lowe thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
it took billions of years but it was a
perfect new life coming from the old
part of it Hartman part of it frozen a
constantly moving blend of atmospheric
elements kept the thermostat perfect to
support the delicate balance it has been
called a miracle and when you see how
perfectly everything works together you
realize that it is but today the earth
is warming if it continues and what
quenched our thirst will flood the land
what filled our plates will turn to dust
nature is not doing this we are nature
cannot stop it we can but we have to
start
[Music]
[Applause]
it's the only planet known to sustain
life the only one whose atmosphere has
been regulated by nature to create the
perfect balance but today the earth is
warming and nature's not doing it
unfortunately all of us know someone who
has the power to do something
[Music]
okay we need to cut it off thank you
very much
those of you who may not know him that
was Patrick Stewart who's the voice of
Captain Picard on Star Trek
finally we come to physics Frank will
check is his the father one of the one
of the fathers of the now very
successful model which accounts for
almost everything that can happen in
present laboratories so this the Frank
will check his professor at the
Institute for Advanced Study in
Princeton and his talk is entitled
quarks and gluons the story of the
strong interaction
[Applause]